all right we'll see you tomorrow i'm
laura ingram this is ingram angle from
washington tonight
humiliated and horrified that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now today is just another day of
disasters in biden world it's constant
humiliation for the president himself
and a total embarrassment for the united
states
it's happening so frequently that we're
almost getting numb to it
now first it's humiliating that biden is
so cringy and creepy
the human sniffer somehow still can't
control himself around the locks of a
young lass
this time on a bike trail in delaware
but you see that what is wrong with him
and if you're going to use like cheesy
pejoratives when referring to your
political adversaries it may be nice to
learn how to pronounce them
my hope is
that the republican party moves back to
a more normal position it's not this
mega party that it's become in many ways
is it magga mega or mommy can i buy a
vowel
all right next biden humiliates america
with his son hunter's rank corruption
and all that mystery money made in china
burisma the prostitutes the crack now
they're bad enough
but they're frankly the least concerning
of all we still don't know who's buying
hunter's lousy paintings that magically
sell for hundreds of thousands of
dollars he blows them through a straw
apparently
it's all shady there's no potential at
all for bribes or kickbacks
yet isn't our press supposed to step in
to report on these humiliating and
outrageous scandals
nah
all the way back to the campaign they
swooped in for the rescue people wanted
really to see you get mad when trump
started lying about hunter well you know
i i
i would like to be able to
be back in high school and just have he
and i in a room as a mother how hurtful
have these attacks been
um on hunter for you they've been really
hurtful i mean yeah
okay that was humiliating for the media
and a humiliating performance by jill
it's embarrassing
okay
jill's bad acting we know now from
hunters reportedly leaked text messages
from the laptop from hell that the two
of them had a terrible relationship
i mean really bad so who's smarter the
druggie or the doctor
as unique as the breakfast tacos here in
san antonio
2.07
without the bag
i think it's a tie but it's very
embarrassing but the real humiliation
for america isn't the family drama or
joe's shuffling and stumbling it's what
he's doing to the once great economy of
ours that was handed to him by donald
trump
today we saw the biggest gain in
consumer prices since 1981 and the
humiliation that keeps on giving you bet
because here's our vice president trying
to reassure the public
there is no question that we still have
work to do
but it is important to note that these
numbers do not fully reflect the recent
drop in gas prices
average national gas prices have fallen
every day for nearly 30 days
she doesn't even look like she believes
it right i mean yeah saving a few cents
a gallon here and there time to pop open
the champagne america
well i paid six dollars and three cents
this morning in maryland
when i look at this report i don't see
any relief anywhere we even before we
got to this 9.1 percent there had been
some sectors that were behaving a little
bit better i look at rents going up i
didn't see any relief in apparel
red red red
by year three of the trump
administration remember we had no
inflation and we saw median incomes
rising
but now well wage growth is declining at
historic rates
the situation is so bad that obama's
former chief economist
says it's terrible right now but as
cataclysmic as the biden economy is for
american families one of the most
humiliating aspects of the entire
charade
is our open border
now look at this sea of humanity
crossing now at eagle pass texas
a country that refuses to control its
border
i mean is it a country at all
this dereliction of immigration
enforcement is an impeachable offense
i'm going to say it again it's an
impeachable offense
it's hurting and it's changing our
entire country
it allows deadly fentanyl to pour in
enriches the cartels strains our budget
look at what it's going to do to our
healthcare in our schools
and as president trump said in 2015
they're sending their rapists
including 27 year old gershon fuentes he
was just arrested for raping a 10 year
old girl in ohio on at least two
occasions and according to an ice source
he is here of course illegally
and of course the humiliation for
america overseas gotta get into that
because that knows no bounds
last summer was the botched withdrawal
of afghanistan
leading to the deaths of 13 service
members and a self-inflicted afghan
refugee nightmare unfolding here
and now we're being humiliated in
ukraine
spending more than seven billion dollars
so far only to see russia making
significant advances
and now there are new fears that the
weapons that we are sending there could
be trafficked or smuggled elsewhere
so when will this humiliation end
we're almost five months into this uh
sir and gasoline natural gas food prices
rising are you concerned uh when you
look at the resilience of this alliance
when these are the economic pressures i
said at the time when we imposed
sanction on sanctions on
on russia it was going to hurt everybody
we're going to but it was the price of
being able to keep this guy from being
able to
succeed and i think it's important so
how long is this going to last longer
when we're there until it takes whatever
time it takes we cannot let them prevail
it can take months it can take years it
could
whatever
and in what is biden's worst humiliation
of all the fact that he's essentially
owned by china
china's military has to be laughing
about how easy it was recently to scare
off a u.s destroyer on the open sea
and of course china's humiliation of
biden is far-reaching
it's been partnering with russia
against the u.s and ukraine since the
beginning of the war
it's claiming neutrality right but
funding russia through oil and ag
purchases
and china's emboldening other countries
to blow us off as well including india
and brazil they're summarily ignoring
biden's pleas to sanction russia over
ukraine
and not only is china stiff-arming us on
russia
it looks like we're then going to reward
them
by dropping trump's tariffs
it is the epitome
of humiliation
uh that is unless you focus for five
seconds on the fact that joe biden has
sabotaged our energy independence it's
hamstrung our oil and gas industries and
is now going hat in hand to muhammad
muhammad bin bonsa salman begging for
oil total humiliation
we could go on and on because under
biden and biden land the humiliation of
america never ends
but what we all need to understand is
that the biden team doesn't really feel
humiliated at all
they think their low poll numbers are
due to a messaging problem you heard
them out there today trying to message
their way out of this
they don't care if the hunter is
compromised and making money corruptly
they certainly don't care about
inflation or if gas prices are too high
they definitely don't care about schools
failing our kids or if china is pushing
us around
those aren't points of humiliation at
all to them
in fact at some level
they believe america deserves to be
humiliated
america deserves to be brought to heal
and ultimately to bend to a new
international order
but i'm wagering that the voters in
november are going to show biden's party
that they don't much like being
humiliated by individuals whose
incompetence goes hand in hand with
their anti-americanism
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else